et avec nous pour ce club deux
économistes bonjour Jean-Marc Daniel
merci d'être avec nous professeur et
mérite à le SCP Europe et match plates
bonjour Merci d'être la directeur adjote
du département analyse prévision de
l'Observatoire français des conjonctures
économiques Alex nous a rejoint bonjour
on va revenir avec vous sur la locution
des manuels Macron et on parlera de
l'inflation du pouvoir d'achat qui reste
le sujet d'inquiétude et de
préoccupations majeure des Français on
va en parler évidemment tout au long de
ce club mais d'abord Alex on va revenir
avec vous sur la locution d'Emmanuel
Macron il a commencé le chef de l'État
par parler de la réforme des retraites
il en a défendu la nécessité et oui le
président de la République a concédé que
cette réforme des retraites n'avait pas
été acceptée par les Français mais il
l'a jugé véritablement nécessaire pour
rééquilibrer notre régime d'assurance
vieillesse sans baisser les pensions de
retraite sans augmenter les impôts et
puis cette réforme des retraites et
pourrait manuel Macron essentielle pour
une autre raison qu'on a finalement peu
entendu ces derniers mois dans la bouche
du président de la République écoutez
voyez tous progressivement un peu plus
comme l'ont d'ailleurs fait tous nos
voisins européens c'est aussi produire
plus de richesses pour notre pays tout
entier et c'est ce qui nous permet
d'être plus fort d'investir pour notre
quotidien et pour notre avenir et nous
en avons besoin
et voilà travailler jusqu'à 64 ans c'est
aussi un moyen d'augmenter la croissance
c'est un autre but de la réforme des
retraites d'Emmanuel Macron
l'a dit claire Borie hier soir il a
raison le chef de l'État mathioplane
alors il a raison sur le fait que si on
arrive à augmenter le nombre d'heures
travaillées dans l'économie française on
augmentera à la croissance dite
potentielle ça c'est vrai après les
vrais modalités c'est qu'il faut que ces
gens-là restent en emploi c'est à dire
que la condition sinequanone du
fonctionnement de tout ça c'est que
effectivement l'allongement de la durée
de cotisation le report de la gale
traduit par plus d'emplois donc c'est
augmenter aussi le taux d'emploi des
seniors qui est un défi pour les
entreprises
le 31 décembre il avait employé le mot
travail 17 fois et à chaque fois il
explique bien que le pays manqué de
travail parce que le travail c'était la
source de la richesse et s'il y a
d'intéressant c'est que cette semaine
l'OCDE vient de publier des chiffres qui
est la quantité de travail par habitant
et on s'aperçoit que au sein de l'OCDE
nous sommes avec la Turquie et le pays
qui travaillent le moins et donc on a
besoin davantage de travail pour
produire plus l'autre solution c'est
d'augmenter l'efficacité du travail les
gains de productivité or là on a aussi
une statistique qui vient de tomber la
productivité non seulement stagne mais
même elle est en train de reculer et
donc si on veut garder dans ton niveau
de vie si on veut maintenir l'autre
pouvoir d'achat il faut produire et pour
produire il faut travailler désormais
davantage je rappelle quand même que
nous sommes 40 ans après la rigueur et
j'avais regardé ça le le la lettre qui
envoyait Jacques de Laura à l'époque aux
Français en leur disant et on va être
obligé de faire un effort il a dit il y
a deux solutions dans la situation de
déficit extérieur dans laquelle nous
sommes soit on baisse votre pouvoir
d'achat soit on augmente la quantité de
travail nous avons fait le choix
effectivement de plutôt baisser
momentanément le pouvoir d'achat pour
pouvoir rebondir je crois que c'est on
est dans la même situation soit on
baisse ce poids d'achat soit on engin de
la quantité de travail parce qu'on a
exactement le même niveau de déficit
qu'en 83 il a dit à le chef de l'État
cette réforme était nécessaire est-ce
qu'elle était économiquement nécessaire
c'est très fort là cette réforme qui
vient d'être promulguée alors qui est
une réforme à faire sur les retraites
effectivement le corps a montré qu'il y
avait un besoin de financement à
l'horizon 2030 la question je pense qui
qui crispe au total c'est les modalités
de la réforme c'est à dire qui va payer
le coût de cette réforme on voit bien
que la réforme ne porte pas uniquement
sur la durée de cotisation qui aurait
peut-être une valeur on va dire plus
équitable c'est-à-dire que tout le monde
devrait avoir la même durée de
cotisation pour un taux plein la
question est du report de l'âge légal
pour des gens qui auraient eu déjà une
durée de cotisation complète c'est ça
que le problème c'est de dire que du
coup une personne qui a commencé
relativement à travailler relativement
jeune qui avant avait le taux plein va
être obligé d'aller jusqu'à 64 ans ce
qui est pas le cas d'un cadre
typiquement qui rentrera tard sur marché
du travail et qui pourra partir à 64 ans
quitte avoir une décote c'est à dire que
si on perd une liberté pour des
personnes qui avaient déjà le taux plein
de partir à la retraite et être obligé
d'aller plus loin donc en fait je pense
que le problème c'est comment on aurait
mieux réparti l'effort en fait de cette
réforme c'est à dire qu'on a un besoin
de financement qui est connu c'est de
savoir comment répartit correctement
au sein des actifs entre on va dire les
travailleurs plutôt classe moyenne et
les travailleurs plus aisés et puis y
compris est-ce qu'il fallait mettre ou
pas contribution les retraités les plus
aisés est-ce qu'on devait parler du
prélèvement ou pas d'une participation
des entreprises au financement global et
donc finalement c'est pas tellement en
terme économique le problème c'est en
termes de d'équité et de justice je
pense derrière ça et le fait que le
dialogue social a été quand même
relativement rompu là-dessus oui sur le
plan de la méthode effectivement c'est
assez calamite à le dialogue social et
en plus c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
et même on est passé de l'absence de
dialogue à l'affrontement donc on est
quand même dans une autre dimension sur
le plan strictement économique je pense
que comme on manque de travail cette
réforme elle s'inscrit aussi dans la
réforme de l'assurance chômage c'est à
dire dans tout un tas de mesure qui sont
comme objectif de d'augmenter la
quantité de travail et donc quand on
regarde par exemple l'OCDE dans ces
commentaires sur la durée du temps de
travail dans un certain nombre de pays
c'est de dire on pourrait aussi
augmenter la durée du temps de travail
des gens entre 15 et 50 ans faire en
sorte que effectivement alors c'est le
débat sur les 35 heures c'est aussi les
débats sur le nombre de jours de fériés
qui est en France c'est le débat sur
globalement comment est-ce qu'on
mobilise la force de travail dans ce
pays ce qui est frappant d'ailleurs
c'est que effectivement le travail est
très intense pendant une période assez
courte de la vie et puis ensuite on
rentre assez tard sur le marché du
travail et on a et on le quitte assez
tôt la deuxième remarque que je fais sur
le régime de retraite en tant que tel
pour rejoindre ce que je viens de dire
Mathieu on aurait pu davantage
solliciter les retraités les retraités
sont les grands absents de la pourquoi
parce qu'en 2017 il y avait une mesure
qui avait consisté un augmentant la CSG
puis avec un remboursement des
cotisations sociales en fait à faire une
sorte de transfert de revenus des
retraités vers les actifs et à l'époque
ça avait été vécu
difficilement assez mal et surtout ça
c'était retrouvé dans les discours sur
les ronds-points des gilets jaunes il y
avait des deux grandes revendications
c'était le prix de l'essence et la CSG
sur les retraités et effectivement les
gens qui tenaient les rond-point c'était
d'ailleurs pour des raisons personnel
assez souvent des retraités et donc là
il y a recule politique vis-à-vis de
cette population et la question qui se
pose c'est pourquoi est-ce que on n'a
pas eu le courage de demander un effort
non seulement aux actifs mais aussi aux
retraités alors vous parlez de la
question du travail hier Emmanuel Macron
pour tourner la page de cette réforme
des retraites à lancer de nouveaux
chantiers dont celui du travail Alex
mais oui le chef de l'État a annoncé
qu'il ouvrait la porte de l'Elysée dès
aujourd'hui au patronat et au syndicat
qui le souhaiteraient pour entamer des
négociations sur la question du travail
avec toute une série de sujets de
discussion qu'il a énuméré hier soir
améliorer les revenus des salariés
faire progresser les carrières mieux
partager la richesse améliorer les
conditions de travail trouver des
solutions à l'usure professionnelle
accroître l'emploi des seniors et aider
aux reconversions
ce nouveau pacte de la vie au travail
sera construit dans les semaines et les
mois qui viennent par le dialogue social
et les accords très concrets au niveau
national mais aussi au plus près du
terrain que les organisations syndicales
et patronales seront trouvées Emmanuel
Macron a aussi rappelé à les actions
qu'ils souhaitent mener dans le domaine
de la formation avec sa réforme du lycée
professionnel avec également un
accompagnement plus approfondi vers le
travail des bénéficiaires du revenu de
solidarité active et puis le président
de la République a ouvert un autre
chantier celui de la transition
écologique de notre appareil productif
grâce à la planification écologique qui
sera dévoilée d'ici l'été nous irons
vers un nouveau modèle productif et
écologique dans l'agriculture le
bâtiment l'économie circulaire les
transports l'énergie et les technologies
et notez que le Président de la
République estime avoir relancé l'indice
l'industrialisation du pays la cité un
chiffre ces deux dernières années 200
usines ont ouvert
des bons points sur l'arrière
industrialisation sur le chômage et il
veut donc lancer relancer ce chantier du
travail il peut le faire
il peut le faire en tout cas il essaie
de le faire je crois que c'est
effectivement un chantier important qui
est extrêmement complémentaire à celui
des retraites mais on voit qu'il arrive
justement à après c'est le passage en
force on va dire sur la question des
retraites il aurait dû être traité pour
moi en même temps qui a un enjeu
essentiel c'est à dire qu'on peut pas
faire une réforme des retraites avec un
objectif d'insérer pratiquement un
million d'actif seniors en emploi d'ici
à 2030 sans parler de cette question du
travail du travail tout au long de la
vie effectivement on a tendance à
rentrer plutôt tard sur le marché du
travail en sortir plus tôt comment on
accompagne justement les seniors et la
formation comment réconcilie ça avec
aussi un chômage des jeunes qui est
relativement élevé donc si vous voulez
vous avez quand même beaucoup beaucoup
de chantiers à ouvrir mais qui sont
nécessaires pour arriver au fait que
cette réforme des retraites fonctionne
et qu'elle est des gains financiers à
terme mais je trouve que effectivement
ça arrive plutôt trop tard c'est à dire
c'était une des conditions un peu oui là
je pense qu'il y avait une ligne des
conditions si nécessaire à la réussite
de la réforme des retraites et là voilà
effectivement je pense que
du Medef donc de toute façon assez
naturellement dans ces cas là les gens
se rencontrent se voient pour mieux se
connaître et donc je pense que il se
content de jouer là un peu les mouches
du coche c'est vous allez rencontrer bon
et sur le fond je pense que ce qu'il a
dit le plus important c'est l'histoire
des lycées professionnels des réussites
de
la précédente c'est quand même d'avoir
augmenté l'apprentissage alors que ça
fait 30 ans qu'on arrête pas de dire
sauf qu'on commence à s'apercevoir que
on est passé d'une logique quantitative
on augmente le nombre d'apprentis la
nécessité d'une logique plus qualitative
regardez effectivement l'utilisation des
apprentissages c'est devenu un des lieux
du décrochage scolaire même dans
l'apprentissage il y a beaucoup
d'apprentis qui s'engagent et puis qui
ne finissent pas leur cycle
d'apprentissage et donc il y a une
véritable réflexion à faire et donc là
je crois que c'est il a mis le doigt sur
un point qui est à mon avis crucial pour
l'avenir économique et pour cette
redistrialisation dont tout le monde
parle alors le chef de l'État a parlé de
du pouvoir d'achat il a parlé de
l'augmentation des prix qui pèsent sur
la vie quotidienne des Français mais a
pas annoncé de nouvelles mesures pour y
faire face est-ce que c'est ce qui
manquait pour vous dans son discours
d'hier ben tu as plein est-ce que ça
manquait je crois que les
malheureusement les marges de manœuvre
budgétaires sont extrêmement réduites
rappelons juste que pour faire face à la
crise énergétique depuis fin 2021 il est
quasiment 100 milliards d'euros qui ont
été mis sur la table qui arrive après la
crise covid où il y a eu un quoi qu'il
en coûte qui était déjà massif
la difficulté qu'on va avoir c'est qu'on
va passer c'est un peu leur décomptes
actuellement et d'ici 2024 on va
retrouver la question de la trajectoire
budgétaire le chef d'État c'est engagé à
ramener les déficits à 3% ou à l'étau
d'intérêt qui remontent donc si vous
voulez les marges de manœuvre elles ont
été déjà pas mal utilisées pour éponger
les crises précédentes et donc
finalement avoir des mesures fiscales de
soutien temporaire pourquoi pas mais il
y a la question premièrement du coup
budgétaire et la deuxièmement du ciblage
et comment on fait autant sur la crise
énergétique c'était un peu plus facile
parce qu'il y a eu des blocages de prix
des remises carburant là sur la question
de l'alimentaire parce qu'aujourd'hui
l'inflation est tirée par l'alimentaire
ce qui n'était pas du tout le cas 2022
qui était très par énergie c'est
beaucoup plus difficile c'est beaucoup
difficile aussi bien cibler les ménages
d'avoir des mécanismes qui permettent de
limiter les hausses de prix donc on voit
quelque part à la fois pour des raisons
techniques mais des raisons aussi
budgétaires finalement il n'y a pas
d'évidence là-dessus et donc c'est vrai
que quelque part il y a pas beaucoup de
mesures dites sucrées c'est-à-dire que
il y a plus de salé que sucrées et
aujourd'hui la question du point d'achat
reste quand même primordial parce que on
constate une baisse du point d'achat
mais qui est coïncidante à cette hausse
de l'inflation cette baisse de la
productivité donc la situation
économique de pays est difficile de
répondre il est difficile de répondre et
on est une association économique du
pays qui est difficile aussi
oui c'est très sûr de pouvoir l'achat et
délicate parce que individuellement les
gens voient bien que la situation est
difficile mais globalement le pays vit
au-dessus de ses moyens je parlais de 83
on est dans la même situation en sens
qu'on a un déficit extérieur abyssal et
à l'époque donc on avait été obligé de
répondre par c'était ça ou les FMI là
maintenant c'est l'Europe d'une certaine
façon qui nous couvre là-dessus
c'est-à-dire que les exportations
allemandes d'une certaine façon
permettent aux Français d'importer mais
l'Europe a des exigences d'abord Mathieu
l'a rappelé sur le plan budgétaire à
partir du 1er janvier 2024 normalement
on revient à la situation normale toutes
les dérogations les quoiqu'il en coûte
auront été normalement à un projet enfin
se termine à partir de la fin de cette
année et puis un certain nombre de pays
c'est il y a une nouvelle charge des
pays frugaux sur le thème écoutez mais
quand est-ce que les Français vont
comprendre que on ne peut pas vivre
durablement ou tu sais moyen au crochet
et ses partenaires européens et donc il
est dans cette situation sachant que je
pense qu'il a deux idées en tête la
première c'est que les plus favoriser ce
qui gagne le SMIC sont protégés par
l'indexation du SMIC je rappelle quand
même pour le SMIC à augmenter de 8%
l'année dernière pour une inflation
affichée entre 6 et 7% bon donc et la
deuxième chose c'est que cette inflation
est en fait liée au prix des
importations il y a la vague de
l'énergie mais là les prix de l'énergie
ont bien baissé là c'est alimentaire
notamment qui était lié à la hausse
considérable des prix des matières
premières agroalimentaires sur à l'été
dernier et là maintenant elles sont en
train de baisser on est même dans une
situation là aussi l'Europe est en train
de dire il y a trop de blé on sait pas
quoi en faire la Pologne hurle en disant
arrêtez de faire venir du blé ukrainien
parce que ça casse les prix il va
falloir faire des aides aux paysans et
donc je pense que l'espoir se crée des
dirigeants c'est que l'inflation va
automatiquement d'elle-même ce tasser on
le voit aux États-Unis et toutes les
prévisions tous les constats d'inflation
sont plus favorables que ce qu'on avait
anticipé et donc je pense qu'il se dit
il suffit de faire le le gros dossier
tous les deux la politique du carnet de
check c'est fini il peut plus la faire
on le voit bien là on constate c'est à
dire que il pourrait y avoir des mesures
comme à nouveau peut-être une indemnité
inflation c'est à dire transitoire sur
certains ménages mais on voit que c'est
assez enfin c'est pas extrêmement
efficace tout d'abord c'est pas
forcément une réponse structurelle à
finalement à changement on va dire
économique assez important du côté de
l'inflation donc oui il y a quand même
une limite de l'exercice et je crois que
cette réforme de retraite s'inscrit dans
une forme alors je vais le mot entre
guillemets d'austérité c'est à dire
qu'on d'ajustement budgétaire de
retrouver des marges de manoeuvre avec
effectivement en travaillant plus
longtemps croissance réduire la dépense
publique y compris dans le PIB donc on
est plutôt dans ce point de bascule donc
c'est vrai que la question du poids
d'achat aujourd'hui va rester assez
sensible parce que on va avoir on voit
les salaires typiquement augmentent mais
ils augmentent moins vite que les prix
d'ailleurs c'est ce qui fait qu'on n'a
pas la spirale inflationniste c'est ce
qui fait qu'on va pas avoir pendant 10
ans une inflation forte mais ça veut
dire que la contrepartie de ça c'est
qu'il y a quand même un choc sur les
salaires et notamment les salariés de la
classe moyenne qui sont au dessus du
SMIC ceux qui sont pas protégés par le
fait que on parle une relation du SMIC
donc la personne qui est salarié dans
une PME qui a pas beaucoup de marge de
manœuvre budgétaire va encaisser 10
points d'inflation minimum en deux ans
donc une perte considérable de son
pouvoir d'achat et donc c'est cette
classe moyenne aussi qui va devoir
travailler plus longtemps aller jusqu'à
64 ans alors même qu'elle a commencé à
travailler à 18 ou 19 ans donc c'est là
dessus à mon avis qui a peut-être un
risque social fort c'est que vous avez
effectivement toutes les mesures ou tous
les ajustements reposent effectivement
sur une catégorie de la population et
vous nous parlez de l'inflation
alimentaire on va voir comment les
Français vivent cette inflation
alimentaire pour tenter de garder un peu
de pouvoir d'achat et bien beaucoup de
Français se ruent vers les enseignes de
hard discount et leurs promesses de prix
bas on regarde sur portage Audrey
lorsque Catherine fait ses courses elle
a les yeux rivés sur les prix la viande
le petit déjeuner l'huile tout en
remonter en fait pour les couches de son
fils de 7 mois elle fait un détour
obligatoire dans cette partie du magasin
le corner de la marque discount du
groupe produit frais épicerie hygiène
tout est au même endroit c'est beaucoup
moins cher ici que d'acheter
de la marque casino comme elle les
clients sont de plus en plus nombreux
sur l'ensemble de la France les vents
ont presque doublés
tout le monde est concerné à l'heure
actuelle par l'inflation l'inflation
alimentaire a progressé de 16% au mois
de mars mais le ressenti est encore plus
haut
25% alors le hard discount fait partie
des solutions pour conserver un peu de
pouvoir d'achat confiture
beurre c'est moins cher des prix plus
bas grâce à des économies logistiques
alors en fait on va développer
notre linéaire en fonction des ventes du
produit c'est à dire que si vous prenez
la biscotte là on va la dimensionner en
rayon par rapport à la vente et on va
faire en sorte que tous les produits
d'un colis rentrent dans ce rayon et qui
est pas de retour en réserve là on va
gagner en économie de personnelle ouais
on va gagner en couple logistique et de
ce fait on va
répercuter ça sur nos prix de vente
cette Français sur 10 fréquente les
enseignes de hard discount et près de la
moitié admet y aller plus souvent depuis
que les prix augmentent il y a un boom
pour toutes les enseignes qui promettent
du prix bas à leur consommateur toutes
ces marques là aujourd'hui elles
apparaissent comme des refuges aux yeux
des consommateurs qui ont peur pour le
pouvoir d'achat et quand on a peur on se
réfugie et en matière de prix vers les
moins chères preuve de cette tendance
l'enseigne de discount non alimentaire
action vient d'être élu marque préférée
des Français
on a perdu du poids d'achat donc on l'a
vu donc en 83 84 au moment de la rigueur
fondamentalement alors je sais combien
de temps ça va durer c'est à dire
combien de temps effectivement voilà
est-ce que cette ponction sur le pouvoir
d'achat a été une fonction qui est
momentanée lié à des la conjoncture
géopolitique ou est-ce que
fondamentalement il y a une espèce de
mécanisme qui s'installe la deuxième
marque que je ferai c'est que dans les
dispositifs qui ont été mis en place en
fait
toutes les aides ont été apportées par
l'État n'ont pas rencontré l'écho qui
s'attendaient je rappelle de chaque
énergie de 200 euros le bilan qui a été
fait c'est que il y a pratiquement la
moitié des gens qui nous qui étaient en
susceptibles de d'y avoir accès qui sont
pas allés le chercher et donc
fondamentalement ça reste quand même
l'augmentation du salaire qui est la
forme la plus simple pour la plupart des
gens de maintien et d'évolution de leur
pouvoir d'agent et ça ça va suffire
alors ça m'a suffire si oui je pense que
les plus bas ont été protégés il y aura
une fonction ça c'était indéniable qui
est lié à cette
est-ce que vous avez dit sur les hausses
de salaire parce que c'est aussi le
discours du gouvernement d'en appeler
aux entreprises pour revoir les grilles
salariale et pour augmenter les salaires
ça va suffire ça
ça suffir non ça suffira pas c'est à
dire que c'est la question du partage de
la valeur il faut avoir en tête que on
subit les économies européennes en
général un choc négatif qui vient de
l'extérieur qui est lié au fait que les
prix de matières premières ont beaucoup
augmenté et donc c'est comment absorber
ce choc dans l'économie donc comment on
partage l'état on prend une partie à sa
charge les boucles tarifaires et toutes
les mesures et puis après c'est le
partage au sein de l'entreprise entre
les actionnaires et le salarié là ce
qu'on voit c'est que les salaires
augmentent quand même de façon
significative par rapport à ce qu'on a
connu par le passé mais moins que les
prix quand même moins que les prix et
donc fatalement vous avez quand même une
baisse de point d'achat alors après vous
avez ce choc macroéconomique et que
effectivement on voit quand même vous
avez des pertes de par l'achat mais
après surtout c'est microéconiquement
très différent c'est à dire qu'il y a
des inégalités qui sont très fortes
entre des boîtes qui ont les capacités
parce qu'elles vont bien parce qu'elles
ont aussi des mécanismes d'intéressement
de primes qui vont pouvoir augmenter
assez significativement les salaires et
puis d'autres qui sont aussi des
entreprises qui sont extrêmement
impactés par la crise covid par la crise
énergétique qui sont des entreprises qui
n'ont pas forcément les insolites qui
vont pas beaucoup de marge de manoeuvre
qui n'ont pas les moyens d'augmenter
donc si vous voulez vous avez ce choc là
qui est la fois ma chronique c'est
comment on se répartit le fardeau en
fait du choc et puis après
individuellement c'est aussi assez
inégalité parce que comme on a dit
certains vont être protégés par
l'inflation d'autres le sont pas des
entreprises ont les moyens d'augmenter
d'autres pas donc si vous voulez il n'y
a pas de réponse il y a pas une seule
réponse possible pour un problème qui en
fait se diffuse dans toutes les économie
et qui est finalement très hétérogène
c'est à dire que selon les secteurs
selon le type d'entreprise selon de
votre type de consommation vous allez
pas avoir le même choc inflationniste et
de pouvoir d'achat
avant de passer aux prévisions oui je
pense effectivement qu'un des gros
problèmes c'est non seulement la
perception mais c'est effectivement le
fait que certains endroits certains
secteurs sont capables de mieux répondre
je et ce sont les secteurs effectivement
les secteurs qui sont les plus
internationalisés qui peuvent aller
chercher la croissance à l'extérieur les
deux endroits dont on a beaucoup parlé
sur les dividendes des bénéfices tout ça
c'est stellantis et total ce sont des
entreprises qui font leur bénéfices à
l'étranger et alors que effectivement
les PME en elle subissent la hausse du
prix de l'énergie même si ça se calme
elle subit effectivement le la hausse du
prix de
l'alimentaire enfin des matières
premières et donc face à cette inégalité
la réponse par l'État est une réponse
qui ne peut pas durer longtemps parce
que il y a quelqu'un qui peut l'état ça
n'existe pas l'état c'est la génération
future en l'occurrence et donc on peut
maintenir notre pouvoir d'achat sur le
dos de nos enfants mais il y a un moment
où synthèse cet exercice assez limite
donc je crois que la bonne solution ce
serait deux choses la première c'est
espérer que l'euro va continuer à
s'apprécier parce que l'appréciation de
l'euro ça allège notre facture
pétrolière et la deuxième c'est le fait
que ce que je maintiens spontanément les
prix vont se mettre à se stabiliser et
comment
français ce matin qui sont inquiets par
cette augmentation de prix est-ce que
vous dites ça va durer est-ce que vous
dites non ça va se calmer je pense que
François villerat de galleau qui est un
personnage raisonnable relativement de
certitude de garantie personnelle alors
on sait pas l'Ukraine ça peut donner des
générer tout ça mais pour considérer que
les 2% sont accessibles assez rapidement
donc ça veut dire que il y a pas
d'espoir que les prix baisses pour
assurer au moins se stabilise
encore certains peuvent baisser je crois
encore on va avoir plutôt une
stabilisation quand on parle aussi de
passer un pic d'inflation on parle pas
de baisse des prix on parle de
réalisation de ralentissement de la
hausse des prix juste enfin nous on
vient de sortir nos prévisions le se sur
cette année déjà avec ce qu'il y a dans
les tuyaux on est à 5,8% en moyenne
d'inflation c'est à dire qu'on a
inflation qui reste quand même
supérieure à en moyenne à celle de 2022
et qui est beaucoup tiré par
l'alimentaire on voit que cet effet du
choc quand même énergie et alimentaire
et important et qu'on a quand même
malgré tout une diffusion sur les
salaires c'est à dire que sinon les
paires de points d'achat c'est
rigolossales donc on a quand même une
diffusion sur les salaires donc
effectivement on n'a pas on n'est pas
dans une spirale inflationniste avec une
inflation permanente mais elle est quand
même relativement robuste elle devrait
progressivement reconverger vers 2% mais
moi je crois pas que ça sera dès 2024
nous on finit plutôt à 3% à la fin 2024
mais ça veut dire qu'on commence quand
même à le reflux de l'inflation est
plutôt à partir de 24 donc 2023 il a des
difficile en terme d'inflation il faut
pas s'attendre à un retournement en tout
cas dans dans les mois à venir et puis
une fois de plus
passer un pic d'inflation voilà une
inflation qui est moins élevée ça veut
pas dire que les prix baisses c'est
juste que l'inflation augmente les prix
augmentent moins vite est-ce que vous
pouvez dire aux gens qui nous regardent
à quel moment ils verront les effets sur
leur porte
2024 ou on pourrait revoir des gains de
salaire réel c'est à dire que les
salaires en fait peuvent rattraper
l'inflation passée c'est-à-dire qu'au
bout d'un moment effectivement on peut
avoir des salaires qui sont un peu plus
dynamiques que les prix mais les années
difficiles c'est clairement 2022 2023
pour la question pour un achat ça veut
pas dire que 2024 sera bien et on va
peut-être certainement arrêter de perdre
du poids la chambre 2024
encore une fois le pouvoir d'achat des
classes moyennes puisqu'il y a des gens
qui sont protégés et le pouvoir d'achat
tu as été le plus touché ce pouvoir
d'achat il va probablement pouvoir
recommencer à augmenter en 2024 avec cet
élément qui était un élément clé c'est
que on est quand même en déficit
extérieur donc on peut pas se permettre
de l'augmenter indéfiniment parce que
plus de pouvoir d'achat c'est plus
d'importation c'est tout le toute la
stratégie de d'Emmanuel Macron c'est
plus de pouvoir d'achat pourvu que ce
soit plus de travail plus de production
plus de croissance et non pas plus
d'importation et donc il faut que le
travail soit au rendez-vous pour
terminer que la crise politique et
sociale qu'on connaît se transforme au
Christ financière
non je pense pas c'était à que d'abord
les banques centrales sur la crise
financière stricto sensuelle et banques
centrales ont quand même beaucoup appris
de la période 2008-2009 donc
elles sont plutôt en situation de
répondre aux difficultés qui ont été qui
sont manifestées récemment et en crise
économique c'est-à-dire là aussi les
éléments qui sont entre nous-mêmes
montrent que c'est ce serait sauf un
choc en Ukraine sauf un choc de cette
nature là il y a encore des réserves
normalement de croissance économiques la
croissance est potentielle est faible
mais elle est pas totalement nulle et
donc un retour à la normale signifierait
non pas de récession en fait il peut y
avoir une ce qu'on appelle une
résistance technique une stagnation et
de ça mais une récession de l'empereur
de 2008-2009 je ne le pense pas non la
question effectivement la remontée des
taux d'intérêt vient percuter un certain
nombre de choses et notamment le système
financier donc on est toujours surpris
de l'origine des crises mais on voit que
le CAC40 reste quand même malgré tout
élevé qu'il y a pas une prime de risque
sur la France par contre je pense que
d'un point de vue politique et
économique c'est la question des quatre
prochaines années c'est quelles sont les
réformes à venir comment elles vont se
faire dans quel climat c'est ça qui peut
plutôt inquiéter je pense c'est pas
faire forcément cette réforme des
retraites ramener l'économie sur
peut-être plus de croissance à moyen
terme réduire les disciples publics mais
on voit que quelque part
peut-être pas une crise économique mais
attention sociale peuvent bloquer quand
même le pays pendant un moment en tout
cas sur des nouvelles réformes à mener
sur des nouvelles d'un dialogues
sociales la stabilité économique sur les
par exemple les ménages n'ont jamais été
aussi déprimés quand vous demandez dans
les enquêtes de conjoncture sur leur
niveau de vie à venir donc on voit que
il faut quand même essayer de retrouver
un souffle aujourd'hui il est clairement
pas là quand merci monsieur vous restez
avec nous si vous voulez bien on va
regarder la une de nos quotidien
régionaux on parle évidemment des
manuels Macron
[Musique]
la presse régionale revient au très
grandes parties sur cette allocution du
président Ben oui avec d'abord un
Emmanuel Macron qui est resté ferme sur
sa réforme des retraites il annoncé son
application à l'automne droit dans ses
bottes à la Une du journal Sud-Ouest il
ne lâche rien titre La Voix du Nord il
tourne seul la page estime le journal La
Charente Libre car même si Emmanuel
Macron a concédé que sa réforme des
retraites n'était pas acceptée par les
Français il l'a jugé nécessaire pour
équilibrer nos comptes sociaux et aussi
pour produire plus selon lui la colère
actuelle des Français n'est pas du
cassette réforme elle est aussi due au
sentiment que actuellement le travail ne
rémunère pas assez bien et le travail
justement ça fait partie des chantiers
qui veulent lancer dans les 100 jours
mais oui effectivement Emmanuel Macron
se donne 100 jours pour relancer le pays
après cette séquence compliquée de la
réforme des retraites c'est à la une du
Courrier Picard et du journal La Dépêche
du Midi et pendant ces 100 jours il
compte mener trois chantiers d'abord un
nouveau pacte sur le travail qui sera
négocié avec les partenaires sociaux des
mesures pour améliorer l'ordre
républicain renforcer les moyens de la
justice mieux contrôler l'immigration et
enfin relancer l'ambition pour nos
services publics notamment l'école et la
santé et puis pendant ces 100 jours
Emmanuel Macron va chercher l'apaisement
c'est ce que retient le journal Le
Télégramme il va annoncer des pistes
pour réformer nos institutions et
essayer de résoudre la crise
démocratique et face à cette à l'option
présidentielle la colère sociale le
faiblipaille et oui hier à 20h il y
avait comme un bruit de casserole dans
plusieurs villes du pays c'est le titre
choisi par le journal La Marseillaise
puisque les opposants à la réforme des
retraites avaient organisé hier un peu
partout dans le pays des concerts de
casseroles pour ne pas écouter ne pas
entendre les mots du président de la
République effectivement la colère
sociale ne s'arrête pas c'est à la Une
du journal l'Ardennais des
manifestations spontanées se sont fermés
hier soir avec parfois des violences
c'était le cas à Lyon la nuit dernière
la mairie du 1er arrondissement de Lyon
et un poste de police ont été pris pour
cible par un rassemblement sauvage qui a
dégénéré à cette à la une du Progrès de
Lyon merci Alex merci beaucoup Mathieu
plage merci beaucoup Jean-Jacques
d'avoir été avec nous merci à tous de
nous avoir suivis on se retrouve demain
et puis à 18h vous avez rendez-vous avec
Thomas eu pour sens publique très bonne
journée à demain
[Musique]